sans espaces être à deux heures de paris
télétravail au grand air autant
d'arguments pour convaincre les
franciliens de s'installer dans l'indre
le pari est lancé pour l' agence
d'attractivité il reste une semaine
avant la fin de la campagne d'affichage
et déjà cinq personnes se sont
renseignés sur le département quitter
paris c'est une chose vient s'installer
sur un département comme le département
doit forcément et quelques modifications
qu'il faut prendre en compte donc la nou
2-2 bien quelque part les aiguilles et
de bien les
les conseillers sur ce qu'est la vie ici
une nouvelle vie où le prix de
l'immobilier est attractif cet agent
reçoit 30 % d'appels parisien
supplémentaires mais seule la moitié de
ces nouveaux clients concrétisent leurs
achats pour lui l'engouement s'explique
par deux raisons
la proximité de paris et puis
l'attractivité des prix enfin c'est
vraiment elle n'a aucune comparaison
les gens qui ont un studio on va leur
allouer un t4 avec un jardin et un
garage chez cet autre agent immobilier
les clients parisiens achètent
majoritairement une résidence principale
et change de vie leur demande
principalement c'est ce type de maison
donc maison isolée son voisin peut-être
mille mètres carrés de terrain des
espaces verts et pas de nuisances au
tour mais tous deux s'accordent sur le
même constat en ce moment les clients
sont pressés d'acheter aujourd'hui les
gens lorsqu'ils viennent et qu'ils
voient le bien qui leur correspond il se
positionne aussi tôt mais donc ce ne
sont pas les seuls et donc il arrive en
ce moment que les personnes fassent des
surenchères sur des maisons
cet engouement nouveau pour l'indre
pourrait permettre de retrouver une
croissance du nombre d'habitants
pour rappel le département a perdu 7500
habitants entre 2013 et 2018